um i'm amy briggs it is wednesday april
13th i think
and i am in princeton new jersey and i'm
walking down prospect avenue which is
the street where all the eating clubs
are
so eating clubs on a sunny spring day
i took a walk down memory lane
i'm a proud alum of princeton university
go tigers
when i was a kid my big sister played
lacrosse here and now my niece kari is
on the team so i came back to see one of
her games
so on my left is the dial lodge which
was an eating club that closed down i
walked down the main drag of eating
clubs which are basically the princeton
version of fraternities and sororities
there are these mansions with big front
lawns lining the street kids are
blasting music and hanging out in the
front lawn and to prove that spring was
really here dogwoods and cherry blossoms
were just starting to bloom
so yeah i am on my way to hogiehaven
which is the place in town
to get cheesesteaks
i'm gonna go get a cheesesteak with
bacon
and i'm gonna eat the whole thing it's
gonna be awesome
[Music]
with cheesesteak in hand i made my way
to the lacrosse field it was a big game
for princeton they were ranked 12th in
the country and they faced number eight
maryland cary was actually hurt and
couldn't play but i wanted to cheer
anyway
i settled into the bleachers with my
parents who live nearby
here on the campus of princeton
university for a name of princeton tiger
lacrosse
[Applause]
not to be all get off my lawn but kids
these days have it pretty good in my
sister's games i remember sitting in
small rows of bleachers watching the
players run around with wooden sticks on
a grass field
but kari plays on an immaculate turf
field there's a jumbotron that shows
slick highlight videos instead of paper
game programs we could download them to
our phone with a qr code it all felt
really professional
once the game started it was clear that
some things never change
[Music]
and the lacrosse dads are very intense
[Music]
nice
at first there was a lot to hear about
good job tigers
that go-go-go is my mom
scored first
and then they scored again
and again
[Music]
[Applause]
three nothing
but in the end maryland proved why
they're a top 10 team they found their
groove and won the game 19-9
ouch
even for an outsider like me it was easy
to see how lacrosse has changed since my
sister played in the 80s
but it turns out there are even bigger
changes happening and princeton's coach
has had a front row seat
hi i'm chris saylor i have been the
varsity lacrosse coach at princeton for
the last 36 years
in chris's very first season she
actually coached my older sister now
she's coaching my niece too which makes
us all pretty proud chris is a low-key
person but she's a huge deal in the
lacrosse world she's in the lacrosse
hall of fame and she's won more games at
the same school than any other division
one coach women's ormans
chris's program used to be a lot more
spartan she remembers when the head
coach had to do a lot more admin work
plus help coach a second sport and even
drive the team van to games we fought
you know and i don't know if i want to
say fight with everything because
sometimes it's just a matter of bringing
it to the attention you know i mean for
years we kids didn't get sports bras
right and now they get sports bras
that's part of what they need to play
like little things like that
um happen over time that you know
players don't even know about
these days it's not just princeton
seeing more investment in women's
lacrosse it's happening all over when
chris started there were about 30 d1
women's lacrosse programs now there are
almost 120. you've seen the sport grow
throughout the country at the college
level you've seen it grow throughout the
country at the high school level and i
don't think that happens out of the
goodness of any
uh university presidents or athletic
director's heart right i mean it costs a
lot of money to have a program in the
past 50 years the number of girls
playing sports has exploded in 1972
fewer than 300 000 girls played high
school sports in the u.s today there are
more than 10 times as many and that
didn't happen out of the goodness of
anybody's heart either
because 50 years ago a federal law
changed everything
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history and this is
overheard a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have here at
nat jao and follow them to the edges of
our big weird beautiful world
this week
title ix turns 50.
in collaboration with espn and disney
we'll explore how it continues to ripple
across american society
we'll look back on this law that
guarantees an equal playing field for
everyone no matter their sex we'll meet
a group of women connected by one sport
lacrosse and hear why it's essential for
women to have opportunities on the field
we'll have more after a short break and
if you like what you hear please
consider a nat geo subscription get
exclusive access to stories published
every single day curated newsletters
delivered straight to your inbox and
unlimited access to our archives going
back 130 years
for more go to natjeo.com
explore more
fifty years ago this month title ix of
the education amendments of 1972 that's
the full name became the law of the land
it's short just 37 words tucked into a
much longer federal education bill
it reads
no person in the united states shall on
the basis of sex be excluded from
participation in be denied the benefits
of or be subjected to discrimination
under any education program or activity
receiving federal financial assistance
in other words anything that a school
gives to men and boys it also has to
give to women and girls when you look
back at it you think well why would you
that's like duh as my nine-year-old
would say duh i'm like well of course
why wouldn't you give the same
opportunities for the girls
as you would for the boys
this is lisa salters she's a long-time
espn reporter you might have seen her on
monday night football or from the
sidelines of nba games
espn is releasing a series of
documentaries called 50 50 that explored
the battle for equal rights in education
and athletics so i asked lisa how title
ix changed the game
[Music]
back then this was monumental this was
groundbreaking um
and it really is something to celebrate
can you explain more about why title 9
is such a big deal i mean how did it
shape the sports world that we know
today
it just
gave opportunities where none existed
before
i was just at a at a celebration of the
indiana
basketball hall of fame where you know
in indiana basketball isn't just a sport
it's kind of a way of life and i was
just listening to some of the older
women talk about the opportunities that
they did not have
because they predated title ix
like they had to go to a gym and play
one day a week because the other six
days
were reserved for the boys
and now today
you know in 2022
if a township or a school tried to offer
a sports program or any kind of program
just for boys and not offer the same
thing for girls
well they would get sued because it's
against the law but even more than that
today they would be laughed at
that's not to say that title ix was a
magic bullet that fixed inequity in
sports that's an ongoing battle and
we'll have more on that later
but it's easy to take for granted just
how seismic title ix really was
in 1972 93 of high school athletes were
boys just six years later girls made up
more than 30 percent of high school
athletes today their share is over 40
percent
and women aren't just playing more
they're finding careers in sports in the
past few years we've seen women shatter
the glass ceilings of nfl officials and
coaches nba coaches and major league
baseball front offices
once people started seeing girls
participating in all all of these sports
once they started seeing
how good women can be how good we can be
at everything if given the opportunity
then it's like a light bulb goes off oh
okay this is what it looks like oh
that's not so bad it's actually pretty
cool
i think people have seen in the 50 years
that if you give women opportunity if
you give anybody opportunities they're
going to make the most of them
to see what women do with those
opportunities i didn't have to look very
far i've played field hockey my entire
life i mean i still play in a rec league
i've seen the doors that sports open and
i can't imagine what my life would look
like without that
plus i have these lacrosse players in my
own family
even though it's been more than 30 years
since my sister played college sports i
wanted to know how it made her the
person she is today
and i was curious what it's like to be
an athlete now 50 years after title ix
so i brought together my sister my niece
and the hall of famer who coached them
both
so good morning
good morning good morning thanks for all
showing up before 9 00 am on a thursday
i appreciate that
first step you want full and last name
yep
so
kari novak
this is my oldest sister kari i'm the
youngest in the family and we have
another sister named heidi in the middle
next up is heidi's daughter arnese
my name is carrie bonanno
i'm a sophomore here at princeton i'm on
the women's lacrosse team
yeah they're both named kari which can
be confusing in the interview we call
them big kari and little kari to tell
them apart and also in the room chris
saylor who's retiring after her 36 years
as the tigers head coach
and i just think it's so incredibly cool
that i have two cars from the same
family really in my first and last year
at princeton it's kind of coming full
circle
it wasn't a given that little kari would
follow in my sister's footsteps in high
school she was a standout who was named
rhode island female athlete of the year
other coaches tried to recruit her but
chris made her feel at home
nice
[Music]
one of my first like princeton lacrosse
camps i ever did
um chris my musta had a sheet um you
know with all the names of the kids at
camp and she recognized kari on the list
and i feel like that was kind of the
first like oh like there's this
connection here um it was really cool
for me i felt kind of famous at the camp
after that like oh she kind of knows she
kind of knows my family at least
so big kari what's it wait what's it
like to watch your niece play for the
same school and the same coach
it's just been great and i feel like
it's kind of
you know reliving this whole thing again
and so there's a part of me that i feel
like car exit this body's a little older
that i would like to keep playing
because i
i feel like i never um finished is uh
kind of where i was so kari you're so
fit right now you could probably slide
right in there with no trouble
so little kari ended up at princeton
after an intense recruiting process
which is pretty typical
kari says that she was already talking
to college coaches before she even
started high school
but back in the day things were very
different for big kari
she's not the kind of person who brags
so i'm gonna do it for her she racked up
some big lacrosse honors in college she
was a regional all-american and she also
made the all-ivy team
but when kari first got to campus she
had never touched a lacrosse stick she
was a field hockey player like me
back then field hockey and women's
lacrosse shared pretty much everything
the same coaches the same field even the
same jerseys
at that time a lot of the girls played
two sports or sometimes three and they
encouraged me to come out for lacrosse
and so one of the juniors at the time
taught me how to throw and catch in a
squash court
and
at that time they had a jv so i was
playing on jv and i remember my first
game extremely well
that i pushed the ball
down the whole entire field because i
couldn't pick it up and the coach is
just crying please pick the ball up
but yeah so that's how it all started
so big kari do you remember your first
impression of coach sailor
when chris came in
you could just feel that there was a
mission happening that she was set to
create
uh something
kari got a taste of chris's intensity
when lacrosse collided with bicker
and princeton bicker is the time when
people pick their eating clubs remember
those big houses i was walking past
earlier they're sort of co-ed
fraternities or sororities and baker is
kind of like rush for a lot of students
it's a big part of their social calendar
and if it is you do not want to miss it
it's changed a lot over the years but
after you pick the one you want to join
you bicker it which often involves some
parties and late nights
it's not exactly conducive to getting up
early for practice but chris isn't the
kind of coach who takes excuses
there are a lot of late nights and
things like that but then practice was
starting kind of right at that time
and you know we were expected to run
you know
x amount of time in two miles or
something like this and you know it was
like well this is what's happening we're
like well we have bicker i mean i'm
gonna fit that in
and so it was just all of this kind of
you know just a new mindset to how how
we had approached things so
i mean coach sailor do you remember this
too i think that's pretty fair
i mean because it was your first season
like were you more determined to be a
hard ass or
well i think i was probably more of a
hard ass by nature than maybe what they
were used to so
well i i just
i particularly remember there was always
that star drill and right and you
couldn't drop the ball
but for whatever reason you'd be like oh
boy here we go again
but i mean afterwards you really built
the program incredibly strong and i
remember
that just watching it going gosh i wish
i could have stayed and you know been a
part of that
coming up princeton lacrosse takes off
even at the top of her game chris has to
fight a possible title ix violation
plus why the cobid pandemic is putting
title ix in the spotlight again
after big cari graduated chris saylor
started to build up her trophy case
she's won three national championships
16 ivy league titles and more than 400
games
and she's seen lacrosse take off
especially in the past 20 years
in the 2018-2019 school year there were
almost 100 000 girls playing high school
lacrosse
those are the most recent figures from
the national federation of high school
sports 20 years ago the number was less
than half that
to be fair it's not just women men's
lacrosse is growing too
but chris says having the force of a
federal law makes it possible for all
those women and girls to play
and i think that's something that
lacrosse our sport has really benefited
from because you've just seen the
proliferation of programs
over the last 10 years and so
you know that having title ix in place
really has provided more opportunity for
women
to compete at a sport like ours at the
college level
so coach taylor have you personally had
to fight for lacrosse or women's sports
as a whole
um
yes i mean yes absolutely um you know i
think we've been fortunate here at
princeton but there are always things
that you try and keep pushing for um
whenever you see that there there are
things that aren't equal and certainly
there are there are some
you you try your best to to keep
fighting for it and and bring to the
forefront
for most of its history princeton didn't
allow women to enroll as normal
undergrads not until 1969.
the first year that women were on campus
the university set aside a women's
locker room complete with hair dryers
chris talks highly of the princeton
administration during her tenure she's
seen them make real commitments to her
program like the fact that they merged
the men's and women's lacrosse alumni
groups so women can reap the benefits of
donations made by male alums
but there was one time when chris
spotted a possible title ix violation
and decided to stand up to her boss yeah
i think it was
in the early 90s there was some
resentment brewing among the women's
coaches we felt that we were
underpaid compared to
the men and and we knew we were doing
similar jobs
i think we had some
some hard data that we had come by to
kind of back that up and
we jointly wrote a letter to um the
athletic director and basically laid out
our case
eventually um i'd say within
a year three quarters of a year
virtually all of the coaches of women's
sports got um
bump ups in there in their salaries um
and i think we felt you know good that
that was the response although i i do
remember it at one point you know that
the sense that oh look what we've done
for you you should be so grateful and i
remember feeling like well maybe if you
back pain me for five years i feel a
little more grateful but i'm glad that
um you know at least there was a
consideration um
for that what was it like to take a
stand like that like were you scared um
i think we were a little scared but we
felt that because we had all of us in it
together
we felt that strength
um in numbers i mean we didn't put down
the gauntlet like if we don't get raises
we're leaving but i think we laid out
you know a case and we were clear that
you know we wanted to see consideration
and
and some action on that and we did get
the response
that we wanted at the time
in the past couple of years women's
sports have faced a new challenge and
title ix is right at the center
the coronavirus pandemic hit college
athletics budgets hard
for some schools the only way to stay
afloat was to cut some sports teams so
they had to make a difficult decision
which ones go away
in division one alone at least a hundred
different sports teams were cut across
more than two dozen schools
and there are many more at smaller
colleges that adds up to thousands of
athletes who can't play and hundreds of
coaches and staff members out of a job
one of those schools was fresno state
university which cut women's lacrosse
along with men's tennis and wrestling
the lacrosse players say they're the
victims of sex discrimination
they're suing fresno state in federal
court
among other violations they say the
university isn't meeting the title ix
requirement to provide proportional
opportunities for women and men
universities have a hard leg to stand on
when they cut women's sports because
you know to be honest i i don't know of
a one that really meets the
proportionality
and maybe there are but i don't know
many that meet the proportionality
standards so you have to you know you
you have to prove you've either met all
the interest
of the students or that you're
continuing to add sports and so cutting
sports when there's clear student
interest and your proportionality
numbers
aren't aligned with title ix and i think
you run into
a real buzz saw with that one
[Music]
the fresno state case is still in court
but other programs are still getting
back on their feet after the coveted
pandemic at princeton most of the 2020
lacrosse season was canceled and so was
last year
in their first full season since 2019
the tigers won the ivy league
championship their seventh in a row
they advanced to the second round of the
ncaa tournament and lost a heartbreaker
to a tough syracuse team
during the season little kari missed a
few games with an injury but she made it
back on the field
you know i've been standing at practice
the last
couple of days and you realize you know
when it's taken away from you how much
you you really love it i mean that's
kind of obvious but um
it serves to be very true i've been
jealous on the on the sidelines recently
so i want to get back there as soon as
possible
as little kari described the training
tools she has access to from the program
it kind of blew my mind when big kari
played the team might give each player
one stick to last their entire career
little kari gets two sticks a year
and remember how it was a big deal when
the team finally provided sports bras
well this year the lacrosse team wears
high-tech clothes that give off infrared
radiation which is supposed to help you
recover faster
i think we're also really fortunate to
have like a lot of really cool
technology that i don't think you guys
were maybe utilizing when when big cars
on the team so you know we're filming
like every practice every game
you know you can't be a competitive d1
team at this point and not be like using
film as like a
as an important tool to kind of like
grow as a team so i think that's huge
for us and so many other aspects of
technology like the polar heart rate
devices that they wear and so you know
we can monitor their training zones and
their cardio loads and make adjustments
for
each athlete i mean things that weren't
even in the imagination of the players
well and not to mention the weight
training i mean we just touched upon it
i think maybe we had two or three
sessions
just to kind of say
maybe this will work
i don't remember what you know i was
only there in your last year but i
remember when i started coaching like
that was on me right i had to design the
program teach the program monitor the
program right there's so much more
support for student athletes than there
was back in the day both men and women
yeah
so i have a final question for each of
you nobody has to answer in any
particular order so jump in if you have
it
so
why is it important to you to play
sports and in particular do you think
it's important to have a law that
guarantees women have equal access to
play them
um i think
it is such
sports are just a part of my life
to me it offered that balance when
you're in school
which was so healthy so it not only did
it give me a community to belong to
and an outlet
to move and participate
um but then allowed me to be the best i
could be
academically to and i'm not saying that
there are not challenges
um involved with that but um
i can't imagine
not being at school and not playing to
be honest i i i don't know what that
looks like because it was just
kind of who i am
so
i'd agree like i don't really know a
time i can't remember a time in my life
that i wasn't ever you know playing
something
um my my family will joke when i'm like
you know in a mood or being annoying
like kari have you have you run today
and like
i just i i was meant to play sports like
i just know that and so
um to have that protected i think is
very important
and i'll say that you know i've had the
privilege of hearing from so many of my
alums since my retirement was announced
and
it's just amazing to me how many of them
say
that the lessons they learned on the
lacrosse field you know those things
they rely on every day
um they've gotten coaching
they know how to take feedback from a
boss they
they've learned how to deal with
different personalities and
i i just think it's invaluable i know it
has been in in my life
and i feel like the lives of women who
and girls who play sports are just
enriched
in so many ways and the life lessons
that you learn
really do make
a positive difference for you
and i'm walking onto campus
from the stadium
and it's
the sun has set but it's not fully dark
yet
um
outside the princeton lacrosse stadium
there's a dedication etched into a
silver metallic plaque
it says
in honor of those athletes of princeton
whose virtues of fair play loyalty
perseverance and unflinching courage are
ingrained in the american character and
manifest on these battlefields
and then there's a latin phrase
and bear with me on my pronunciation qui
audit venchette
those who dare
win
50 years ago the us dared to ensure that
everyone regardless of sex gets the same
opportunities so that women and girls
today could keep daring on the field
hey this is jacob pinner from the nat
geo audio team
we're pushing even farther to the edges
of our big weird beautiful world with a
segment called sound bank
earth one sound at a time
sound bank brings you the world through
the ears of nat geo explorers and
photographers on assignment
this week
two recordings that show why listening
to forests can reveal how healthy they
are
this is a little bit like going to the
eye doctor
i'm gonna play the two sounds and i want
you to tell me which one sounds better
okay ready
number one
or number two
here's number one
and here's number two
so which one is the healthy forest
if you pick number two congrats and you
might have a future as a forest
ecologist
here's why these two sound so different
they come from explorer pooja chokesy
who recorded them in central india
sound number two comes from a healthy
dry tropical forest
not only does this forest have big trees
it also has saplings and smaller trees
on the forest floor
that provides plenty of habitat for
insects and birds and everything else
that makes noise
sound number one however comes from a
forest being overtaken by an invasive
shrub
it's called lantana kamara and according
to puja it can be a menace
the shrub chokes out those saplings on
the forest floor
in the recording the insects and birds
sound far away because there's nowhere
for them to live in this degraded forest
pooja plans to keep listening to the
forest
she says it's a promising tool to
measure change over time
in just a few months since we launched
sound bank we've explored how important
it is to listen
behind the scenes we've pushed the
boundaries of storytelling by using
these sounds to create spatial audio
experiences and we're excited to share
more with you in the coming months
until then
keep listening
all right amy it's all yours
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription you get exclusive access to
stories published every single day
curated newsletters delivered straight
to your inbox and unlimited access to
our archives going back 130 years
plus it's the best way to support
overheard go to nachio.com
explore more to subscribe the link is
right there in the show notes
also in the show notes dive deeper into
the history of title ix find out why we
needed it and how its opponents pushed
back and check out espn's 5050 a
month-long initiative that explores
stories at the intersection of women
sports culture and the fight for
equality that's all in the show notes
right there on your podcast app
this week's episode is produced by
senior producer jacob pinter
our producers are kyrie douglas alana
strauss and marcy thompson our senior
producers include brian gutierrez our
senior editor is eli chen our manager of
audio is carla wills our executive
producer of audio is davar ardella who
edited this episode
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer our photo editor is julie
howe
ted wood sound designs this episode
hansdale sue can post our theme music
special thanks to eve tro and the team
at espn daily and to dan kearns and the
princeton university broadcast center
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners the walt disney
company is majority owner of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
nathan lump is national geographic's
editor-in-chief
and i'm your host amy briggs see you at
hoagie haven
[Music]
[Music]
you